i think a lot of people fall into this
category not terribly overweight
but have some troubled spots some some
problem areas it could be the arms it
could be legs it could be
a lot of different parts of the body
they're just not happy with so what's
the solution
well there may be one robin paul is the
senior consultant with fast fit and she
joins us now to talk about some
solutions how you doing robin
hello hi robin how you doing hi i think
you just
joined us right yeah that was like a
very quick introduction there
so how are you i'm doing great we were
just talking about how some people have
the problem areas it may be the arms the
legs the chin
and it's frustrating for a lot of folks
but there are some solutions
that you guys have at fast fit
absolutely
so a lot of people that come in to see
us yes they need to lose
fat but some people just have these
special areas
these targeted spots which we can do so
basically
um you know you use our technology it
shrinks your fat
cells um your fat cells they look like
grapes and it shrinks that and all that
toxin all that poison
all that fat is released um so we can we
can target those
areas you know those that chin the arms
cellulite
um you know that mid section that hard
to reach area
and you always uh bring with you some
examples of people who have benefited
from this
absolutely let's take a look at some of
those this one
uh what happened this is somebody who
worked on their chin right
i i can't see it but i'll say they did
yes they look great
so we'll as we look through some of
these let's uh
let's continue to talk about how this
works when someone comes in
this is a pretty easy process right oh
it's such an easy process
you come in everything's a spa-like
environment you just relax
you use our technology it's very
welcoming
and really it's amazing not only um does
it shrink your fat cells
and get rid of that dangerous fat that
visceral fat
which is the fat that causes heart
attacks heart disease cancer
a low immune system and even causes
depression we get rid of that
subcutaneous fat as well
um no one else can get rid of that
visceral fat because that visceral fat
sits underneath your rib cage and it
basically
chokes all of your organs so you can't
have that
surgically removed because it's around
your organs so
um you know it's really amazing it also
tightens tones and firms your skin
well the examples we're seeing here are
really
really impressive how long does it
normally take to get results like that
so it all depends on every everyone is
different
but typically you know in 90 days you're
going to
see fabulous fabulous results but
everyone is
everyone is different and um but you get
results very very quickly
all right rob and paul thanks so much
for joining us and uh
want to let people know how they can get
a hold of you fastfitbodysculpting.com
is the website
you can go there or you can call them at
1 800
fast fit in fact the first 20 callers
will receive a special offer fastbit has
locations in summerlin
west sahara centennial and henderson las
vegas now